People, in other words, who don't
believe everything they hear.
In fact, those same people
will believe anything.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann here, and
today I'm going to talk about something
a little different than normal.
I'm gonna talk about Joe
Rogan and language learning.
Remember, if you enjoy my
videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications
and if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
Now, why Joe Rogan?
Well, first of all, I
didn't know who he was.
I'd seen references in media to him.
I knew he was somewhat controversial.
Someone sent me, uh, two links to, uh,
videos, which were part of podcasts
that he did that included the discussion
of language and learning languages.
So I watched them and very interesting.
Joe Rogan, apparently, I looked
him up, he ha he is the most
popular podcaster on the planet.
He has 11 million subscribers.
He puts out three or four podcasts a week.
Each one is like two hours long.
So that's an awful lot of content.
Uh, I don't know if every
one of his 11 million
uh, subscribers listens to every two
hour podcast every, however many times
he, he puts them out each week, but he
obviously does influence a lot of people.
So it was very interesting for
me to, to look at those videos.
Um, this is gonna be a bit of a ramble.
I haven't got it all
thought out ahead of time.
I will see how it goes, but my, my
impression was somewhat negative.
Now that's probably not surprising
given my age and given, you know, I'm
not in tune with the modern, sort of,
um, you know, social media sphere,
but I don't like the way he speaks.
He is very incoherent.
He jumps around, he makes
exaggerated statements, he
uses a lot of foul language.
Uh, nothing of any great
consequence is said.
Um, and I guess this contributes to
his success because he is successful.
He's the most successful podcaster.
Uh, I saw where when he had one rant
where he, uh, was strongly anti-vax
or something, that there was a lot
of controversy because it was picked
up by CNN and that boosted his, uh,
audience by another 2 million people,
which he's attributed to the fact
that everybody knows how unreliable
CNN is, which is again, sort of this
typical exaggerated extrapolation.
There are undoubtedly reports on CNN or
any of the media that are not accurate,
but that doesn't mean that everyone
thinks that they are always unreliable.
I would still consider CNN a more reliable
source of information than Joe Rogan.
And uh, you know, it's interesting,
this idea that, well, you can't
trust this, you can't trust that.
This idea of, well,
you can't believe that.
I, I think a lot of these people who
say, you know, I don't, don't believe
everything you read or everything you
hear, uh, on CNN or don't believe what the
experts tell you, people, in other words,
who don't believe everything they hear.
In fact, those same people will
believe anything, in other words,
uh, completely without any proof
or any, uh, uh, you know, evidence.
Uh, if someone postulates someone like
this Joe Rogan guy, and if this person is
popular, then uh, this becomes sort of a
symbol of, I don't believe everything that
I'm taught, but you'll believe Joe Rogan.
Anyway, bit of a, an
introduction to the subject.
So then I listen to him interviewing
this guy and the conversation is
kind of like, like, man, like, uh,
look at this crazy f***ing writing
system like Chinese or Russian,
like, how can you ever learn that?
That's crazy, man.
That looks like, looks like a
spade with a knife through it.
Like, that's crazy.
Well, yeah I learned, uh, Spanish
at school for a year and, uh,
got to where I could almost
speak and then I forgot it all.
It's just crazy.
Everything's crazy.
Well, yeah, like, man, like wow.
Um, you know, learning a language
is the hardest thing you can do.
It staves off your mental
deterioration, like, or atrophy he
said, like, it's all exaggerated.
I prefer people who, and I would
definitely suggest to people who
are working on their English,
don't speak like Joe Rogan.
Uh, learn to speak, you know, in,
in, in a way that makes sense.
That you know, where you, arguments
are built up logically where things are
explained based on available evidence.
Where it's measured.
There's a bit of this and a bit.
It's not to say that, by the way, I'm
leaving the links to those two videos
in the description box, but I mean,
there's stuff there that's perhaps
true or partly true or or legitimate,
but there's a lot of very incoherent,
childish, um, misstatements or
exaggerations or childish observations.
And I really don't understand why
anyone would listen to much of that.
Um, but I, I made some notes of what he
said, but I'm not gonna bother with it.
Um, yeah, uh, I mean, you're
not learning to speak English
well if that's why you listen.
You're not learning anything meaningful.
Listening to Joe Rogan, I think
there's a, there's a, a definite lack
of respect for language like, Uh,
some other writing system: Arabic,
Chinese, Russian is not crazy.
Uh, you know, they took, he
says at one point they took our
letters and used them backwards.
They're not your letters.
It's a Latin alphabet.
There is a Cyrillic alphabet,
which he calls acrylic.
Each one of those is, has
had its own development.
Like it's this whole idea that, you
know, we are the norm and everything
else is weird, crazy strange.
Actually anyone can learn any language.
No language is strange.
No language is weird.
Uh, so there's this lack of respect
for a variety of, of, of, of
languages, our ability to learn these
languages, but we have to stay with it.
And, uh, making it seem like
some very strange, weird
thing, very difficult to do.
And whatever time you put into it,
you're gonna lose it right away.
And none of this is true.
Um but, uh, by all means, people should,
should listen to whatever they wanna
listen to and draw their own conclusions.
But the important thing is
to draw your own conclusions.
And I think too often in today's
world, it's more a matter of saying
something, you know, outrageous.
And if what you say is outrageous
enough uh, people will follow
you.,As was the case with Joe
Rogan, who picked up 2 million
additional listeners simply by saying
something outrageous about vaccines.
There seems to be this competition of
who can say the most outrageous things,
and not only outrageous, but incoherent.
So if you combine outrageous
with incoherent, then you're
challenging common sense.
You're challenging the accepted, accepted
wisdom and therefore you're worth
listening to because you're kind of way
out there and throwing a few F-bombs
and, and foul language and a few wows
here and there, and some strange obser...
childish observations.
And this seems to appeal to people.
Unfortunate, I mean, he has 11
million listeners to his podcast.
That is an awful lot that
makes him very influential.
Uh, I don't know.
A best seller is a million copies.
People don't read those books
necessarily, even if they buy them.
Uh, it's easy to listen to a podcast.
You're listening in your car, you're
hearing all this stuff, uh, based off
and on very little, just the sort of
impulse of a guy like Joe Rogan, his
prejudices, what he heard somewhere,
not quite sure where he heard it, but
it must be true because it's contrary
to what they say in the mainstream.
And all of this stuff is, I think,
let's just say I don't like it.
I think that, uh, to learn
languages, you have to respect
the language you're learning.
You have to respect the
process of learning a language.
You have to respect people
who speak different languages.
In other words, treat
the subject with respect.
And if we want to encourage people
to learn languages, which I try to
do at this channel, then um, we need
to present it in a positive way.
Now he's not interested
in promoting languages.
He just wants to sound off and thinks he's
funny and get somebody on there that will
chime in with him and drop a few F bombs.
And that's his shtick and
it seems to work for him.
And uh, obviously he's really
wealthy from doing that.
But, uh, being wealthy and having a
large following doesn't necessarily
elevate him in my, uh, mind.
So there you have it.
You might be interested in a video
that I did a while ago on Jordan
Peterson, who is another popular figure
in this sort of social media sphere
challenging established, uh, you know,
conventional wisdoms and so forth.
Um, and, uh, maybe another one that's
a little bit more positive about
the importance of language learning.
Thanks for listening.